hi I'm Annie whoo and I'm a mathematics
teacher the involvement of parents in
the learning process and partnership
with them between teachers in the
community is is so important but as a
secondary teacher I'm very familiar with
how intimidated many parents can become
you know even as they got to year five
and six parents are starting to realize
what people are kids are learning
addition and division in totally
different ways than I experienced when I
was a kid and that can be a it's a very
fearful kind of thing to contemplate let
alone when they get into the senior
years and thinking about you know
calculus and statistics it can be
something quite frightening but I think
it's important to develop that
partnership and you know to illustrate
that I think about say on Wikipedia
there is no English anxiety page there
is no science anxiety page but there is
a maths anxiety page and one of the
things that is so clear in the way that
we view mathematics is that emotional
resonance by the positive or negative
really is something that sends strong
messages to our children and so we
absolutely need to have parents on board
and one of the things that I love
telling parents and it's sort of a
freeing kind of reality is you don't
have to be an expert at mathematics to
help your child grow mathematically what
you need to be is open to say okay what
did you learn today and maybe I can
learn something about that as well what
it requires is the ability to question
okay
this calculus thing can you tell me what
it's really about what does it apply to
in your everyday life what's something
that it connects to in my life as well
those little things don't require
expertise but they do require a
disposition of saying I want to learn
that I'm willing to come along with
journey with you
[Music]